The work that I've
been doing at MIT
focuses on finding
individual memories
in the brain
and then trying to actually
tinker with those memories.
Can we turn them on,
can we turn them off
can we change the contents
of those memories?
Ethical stuff aside, you can
imagine the implications
for things like
actually being able to
activate memories in
Alzheimer's, for example.
Or using memories to
combat certain symptoms
associated with
psychiatric disorders.
The main question that
we started off
tackling was,
can we go in,
can we find the brain cells
that are active during
a particular memory
and again, can we actually
modulate those brain cells.
So, what we would do
is, uh, we would go in
we would find
these brain cells that
we think are holding
on to a particular memory
and we would actually
artificially install
a light-sensitive switch
in those brain cells.
So, that means that we can
actually take an optic fiber,
do some careful brain surgery
and actually shoot
lasers into the brain
and reactivate these brain cells
or inactivate these brain cells
that we think are housing
a particular memory.
You don't have
to imagine any more
the possibility of
bringing back a memory that
was once thought to be lost,
in a patient with Alzheimer's.
Or imagine going in and
turning the dial down
on the emotional gut-wrenching
"I hate my life" feeling of...
not a breakup but something more
seriously, something like PTSD.
Imagine being able to
turn the dial down
on those negative emotions.
Or being able to jump start
particular moods
when your mood is really low
or even under depression,
uh, in a depressed state.
So, those are the things that we
don't have to imagine any more.
Those are the things that
we are on the cusp of
actually being able to do
with, I think, powerful
therapeutic value.